Speaker 1: Let's start today with the latest
on the train derailment in East Palestine,
Ohio. There's a bunch of different stories here.
There is, of course, the regulatory story. There's
the story of what caused this definitively.
There's the Pete Boudette judge story, which is
building even among some on the left and saying,
okay, even if it's not Pete, Budda Judge's fault,
why did he not react or act quickly after it
happened, which we will talk about separately. But
in the immediate, there is the story about what
is going on with chemicals and risks to people's
health. Now, I want to start and preface this
by saying this is not a conspiracy theory show.
We debunk conspiracy theories. And when we talk
about what's really going on with the chemicals
in East Palestine, Ohio, we are not even needing
to take the position that there is a conspiracy
of some kind here. We just know that there is
a history of wrongly assessing health risks
to people from chemical elements of different
kinds, and of being slow to tell people of that
being the case. So when we look at this article
from The New York Times, which says many in East
Palestine skeptical of official tests, seek out
their own, it is not a conspiracy theory to say
the government, whether it's federal or state,
hasn't always been right or honest initially about
these things. And so we want more information. The
New York Times says the moves reflect residents
deep seated mistrust of government screenings,
of toxic chemicals and fears of long term effects
from the train derailment. So this is a crazy
situation that's taking place. This is Ohio. And
people you can check out the article, people who
are not satisfied with what they were being told
about toxic chemicals have been paying independent
contractors to evaluate what is going on,
trying to find tests of their own. And you can
read the details and you can read the names of
the different chemicals and you can read the
statements from Norfolk Southern as well as the
state government. But there is a very long history
of this. So, yes, one part of it is, wow, people
are paying. People are so desperate to know is
what's in the air, in the water. Are these things
harmful to my health, to my family's health?
People are so desperate and they are distrustful
of the government to such a degree that they're
going into their own pocket, an area that is not
a rich area by any means, and saying, we're going
to try to figure out how we can pay to get real
answers here. This is reasonable. This is not a
conspiracy. When you look back. I mean, listen,
you don't have to think back very far. Look at
the Flint water crisis that's under a decade ago,
the city of Flint, Michigan. We've talked about
this so many times, changed its water source
from I believe it was from Lake Huron. Huron.
I don't even know how you say Lake Huron to the
Flint River. And it was going to be, at the end
of the day, a money saving thing. And the river
water was corrosive. It caused lead to leach
from old pipes, it contaminated drinking water.
And the latest I saw months ago is that the people
of Flint are still on bottled water and it took
years to resolve it. There were denials. There
were all sorts of claims made that everything's
fine and everything was not fine, and people
ultimately were indicted. And then there's so
many other cases. In the 1970s, there was the Love
Canal. Love Canal, the neighborhood of Niagara
Falls, New York. Remember, you've got Canadian,
Niagara Falls and America, Niagara Falls. And
residents of Love Canal discovered that their
homes and properties were built on a toxic waste
dump. Massive dumps, not a satirical term in this
case. And those chemicals in the dump were linked
to health problems, birth defects, cancer, etc.
The risk was initially downplayed by governments
and it took years to eventually evacuate
residents. There's all these other examples. We
saw it with Agent Orange. We saw it with tobacco,
we saw it with Three Mile Island. So it is not a
conspiracy theory to say there is a record of
when these sorts of things happen. Governments
either out of ignorance or out of wanting to
keep people calm for lack of a better term,
giving information that is wrong. And whether
it's deliberate or not doesn't really matter
when you're talking about the health of your
family. So that's where we are right now.
Joe Biden making a last minute trip to Ukraine,
but the complaints are the Biden administration
isn't sending enough people to Ohio. A failed
former president Donald Trump now says that he
will go to Ohio to the site of the derailment
on Wednesday. I don't know the details of that,
but if it's possible and if there is a public
facing event, we will try to cover that. And
if Joe Biden goes, we will try to cover that as
well. But that's where we are. And it is unclear
at this point how the residents of Ohio right
now get definitive answers about water and air
and soil and those sorts of elements. Eventually,
I'm sure we will get the full story, including
from official entities. But right now I would
be skeptical as well. You don't have to ascribe
malicious intent to it yet. But I would also be
skeptical that the full scope of this is known